ok alors pour mon anniversaire
à propos du Congrès des ventes dont je
t'ai parlé et ben apparemment je vais
devoir y aller en fin de compte pourquoi
je crois qu'ils ont pensé à moi c'est
tout je t'aime Alice
je suis contente de vous voir
joyeux anniversaire
à toi
Alice est-ce que ça va désolé c'est
juste Simon
ma belle fille
avez-vous vu cette jeune fille non on
est arrivé seulement hier
salut mon amour non je t'entends bien
qu'est-ce
qui se passe je vais peut-être devoir
partir plus tôt que prévu depuis quand
il est plus important que nous à tes
yeux
[Musique]
te voilà ma belle
on savait pas que tu venais je suis sûr
qu'à lise va tout m'expliquer
est-ce que tu regrettes de m'avoir menti
comment on est censé être heureux
ensemble si on peut pas se faire
confiance
[Musique]
pourquoi tu lui as menti tu peux pas
faire une autre erreur
[Musique]
c'est toi qui m'a dit qu'elle te
connaissait pas vraiment
[Musique]
j'essaie de te prouver que je t'aime
réellement
mon bel amour